legal eagle is coming in loud and clear
thanks to ting immobile the coronavirus
is the only thing that people are
talking about anymore and rightfully so
it's a novel virus causing significant
illness and death we don't know much
about it and it's spreading at a rapid
pace countries around the world are on
lockdown the CDC recommends avoiding
gatherings of more than 10 people and
several US states have closed bars and
restaurants and millions of people are
suddenly working from home unfortunately
it seems like in the u.s. things are
worse than they need to be the person
responsible for coordinating the
American response to the pandemic is of
course the President of the United
States and as Donald Trump once said in
2013
leadership whatever happens you're
responsible if it doesn't happen
you're responsible no I don't take
responsibility at all fast forward to a
few days ago with cities and states
taking the lead in terms of the
coronavirus response President Trump has
been heavily criticized for his response
so far is the criticism warranted or is
everyone just picking on the ex reality
show host for no reason presidents from
Truman to Reagan to Obama all agreed
that the buck ought to stop with them
President Harry Truman even had a sign
on his desk in his farewell address
Truman said the greatest part of the
president's job is to make decisions big
ones and small ones dozens of them
almost every day the president whoever
he is has to decide he can't pass the
buck to anybody no one else can do the
deciding for him that's his job so is
Donald J Trump doing his job my
administration will take all necessary
steps to safeguard our citizens from
this threat today we're going to look
with a critical yet objective eye and
what the US government is doing whether
it's doing enough and whether it made
things worse
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because we're all quarantined
in our houses and what else are weakened
into the account of the US government's
response or lack thereof to the
coronavirus is a story in three parts so
let's begin with part one by failing to
prepare you are preparing to fail
Benjamin Franklin our story begins one
week before president Trump's
inauguration when Trump's team
participated in a role-playing exercise
with Obama's administration about how to
prepare for a major emergency the
possibilities of emergencies included
cyber attacks hurricanes and pandemics
the purpose of this exercise was to show
the president how to respond to a
massive emergency this included a
scenario about a very contagious
flu-like virus that spread through Asia
and Europe to America the players
actually discuss things like ventilator
shortages the need for a vaccine
possible travel bans and coordination
with state and local governments the
Trump team was told pandemics can start
in other countries and don't respect
borders science must guide decisions
federal and state collaboration is key
consistent messaging is needed social
distancing is recommended and days and
even hours can matter the Obama
administration had one goal in mind
getting ready to battle the worst public
health crisis since the 1918 influenza
epidemic which public health officials
thought was inevitable if you're
inclined to dismiss this as fake news
Politico has the actual documents for
this missed opportunity as you can see
from the role-playing meeting the Obama
administration created a plan for
handling a crisis that would be similar
to the h1n1 virus issues for discussion
included hospital preparedness and
response funding from Congress and
collaboration between state and federal
health officials
although Trump's administration was
involved most of the 30 people who
attended the meeting are no longer
government employees although President
Trump later said we were all surprised
by the pandemic that might have been
true because he dismissed all the people
who weren't surprised of course the loss
of qualified career professionals in the
government has been a persistent
criticism of the Trump era President
Trump made one of the most consequential
decisions of his presidency back in May
of 2018 when he disbanded the pandemic
response office which President Obama
created to get ready for a global virus
when President Trump was asked what
responsibilities he took for display
ending the whitehouse pandemic office he
took no ownership we've saved thousands
of lives because of the quick closing
and when you say me I didn't do it I
don't know anything about it I mean you
say you say we did that I don't know
anything about it but why did he do it
here's presidents from explaining his
decision back when he made it some of
the people we cut they haven't been used
for many many years and if we have a
need and we can get them very quickly
and rather than spending the money and
I'm a business person I don't like
having thousands of people around when
you don't need them when we need them we
can get him back very quickly and in a
crazy twist that's probably just due to
bad writing
Trump's partner in crime in disbanding
this particular office was none other
than former buddy turned frenemy John
Bolton president Trump's denial that he
had anything to do with the pandemic
response office closing didn't go over
well with senator sherrod Brown who
reminded President Trump that vote I
wrote you more than 600 days ago
demanding answers after you fired the
entire White House pandemic team and
then brown brought the receipts so yes
Trump cut the pandemic office one year
after he took office of course it is
somewhat ironic that President Trump has
tweeted about Obama's handling of the
2014 Ebola crisis nearly 100 times he
criticized President Obama for allowing
US citizens with Ebola back into the
country complained about President Obama
flying people in from all over the
country for meetings and said Obama was
quote selfish for playing golf
yes he criticized someone for playing
golf unfortunately that's not where the
poorly timed budget cuts end the
president also cut the Health and Human
Services funding by 15% cut 1.2 billion
dollars from the funding for the CDC and
removed 35 million dollars in the
funding for the infectious disease rapid
response reserve fund from the budget
the cuts to the funding and the
personnel were made under the notion
that the government could always get
them back if they were needed later on
but as of the time of this video that
largely hasn't been the case and despite
warnings the Trump administration has
generally been very slow to recognize
the danger that the corona virus has
posed as you're probably aware the
corona virus is spread from person to
person contact through droplets it can
live for up to two to three days on a
hard surface the virus can remain
asymptomatic for quite some time which
means that people can spread it to
others for weeks before realizing that
they are
fact infected themselves with this
community spread pattern it's now clear
that countries like Singapore and South
Korea which aggressively tested people
and put those people who tested positive
into quarantine have had great success
in containing the disease countries like
Italy on the other hand which responded
slowly and didn't do widespread testing
saw the disease metastasized quickly
Italy now has over 27 thousand cases and
over 2,100 deaths they've closed schools
shops sporting events and ordered people
to quarantine in their own home which
brings us to part two of this story you
can't fight what you can't see or I like
the numbers where they are like Italy
the United States was slow to recognize
the need for widespread testing the
administration's unwillingness to ensure
that as many people as possible got
tested and tested early before the virus
had a chance to spread further likely
has caused it to spread unnecessarily
within a week of its first case of
coronavirus South Korea had tested more
than 66,000 people as of March 17th
the US has just barely tested 30,000
people and there are still big problems
with the testing process as we've
learned the hard way there is a big
public policy trade-off between
extensive testing and later draconian
measures the more that you test and the
more that you can isolate the people who
are infected the less the population in
general has to quarantine themselves but
when you don't have testing then people
need to isolate as a preventive measure
as can be seen by this chart the United
States has been significantly behind
testing for the krona virus as opposed
to other countries as of March 11th only
23 people per million people living in
the United States have been tested it
lags behind the entire industrialized
world the United States could have used
the coronavirus test published by the
w-h-o back in January which was based on
a previous German test instead the u.s.
decided to create its own test which
would have been fine if it worked but
science is hard and it didn't the
American test turned out to be more
complicated than the German test and
when it went out to labs the results
were inconsistent and the CDC had to
ship new tests with new chemical agents
this caused a huge delay and as people
had been exposed to the virus continued
to infect others
in the meantime individual states
developed their own tests but had to
wait for the FDA's emergency approval
process as of February the CDC's test
continued to come back with errors so
dates and cities did not have accurate
testing kits ready at the start of the
epidemic and as the testing issue became
more and more urgent president Trump
deflected on whether people should even
be tested you know a lot of people think
that goes away in April with the heat
instead it appears the president fixated
on keeping the numbers low so it looked
like the infection was less than it was
and potentially better than other
countries you may ask about the corona
virus which is very well under control
in our country we have very few people
with it on March 8th the president said
I would rather because I like the
numbers being where they are I don't
need to have the numbers double because
of one ship at the time President Trump
made that statement 17 people had died
from the corona virus and only six
thousand people in the entire country
had been tested when asked about the
fact that the rich and famous like
basketball players and actors seem to be
tested at much higher rates the
president said recently that that's just
the story of life do the well-connected
go to the front of the line well that
kid have to ask them that question and
when asked Americans were scared though
I guess nearly 200 dead 14,000 you're
sick millions as you witness who are
scared right now what you say to
Americans we're watching you right now
you're scared I say that you're a
terrible reporter that's what I say it's
not clear that the Trump administration
has fostered an environment where
experts are allowed to talk objectively
without fear of reprisals from the
president there have been reports that
various health experts were prevented
from talking to the President and other
health experts were stymied from making
public statements and although President
Trump said he would theoretically bring
back all the experts he fired from the
pandemic response office when it came
time to manage the crisis he turned to
his reliable vice president Mike Pence
Mike will be working with the
professionals and doctors and everybody
else that's working the team is is
brilliant we all certainly hope for the
best but Pence's prior experience
handling public health concerns is not
exactly reassuring as the governor of
Indiana pence cut public health spending
and delayed the introduction of needle
exchanges even though experts warned
that it would cause an HIV outbreak
which is basically exactly what happened
Pence's actions led to Indiana's worst
ever HIV outbreak they've established
great health care they have a great
system
Pence's other contribution to public
health was probably when he declared
that smoking doesn't kill which he said
in 2000 more than 30 years after the
Surgeon General first link to smoking to
lung cancer and heart disease he's got a
certain talent for this and Pence's few
public statements haven't exactly been
confidence-inspiring for example on
March 3rd pence claimed that any person
in America could be tested which wasn't
true then and still isn't true today
almost three weeks later now declaring a
national emergency gives the president
the opportunity to dip into FEMA's 40
billion dollar disaster relief fund
under the Stafford Act which governs the
emergency provisions the president is
authorized to give federal agencies more
authority and flexibility in providing
shelter and transportation for people
who have the virus and although many
people suggested the President Trump do
this doing so would make things seem
like you know a national emergency
so instead at the time President Trump
turned to his presidential advisor Jared
Kushner and in addition to figuring out
whether an emergency declaration was a
good idea or not Jared turned to his
family for medical advice in particular
he turned to Kurt Cloths a doctor whose
daughter Karlie Kloss is married to
Kushner's brother doctor Kloss
did what many of us would do in this
situation he turned to Facebook and as a
result of the information that he
obtained from a Facebook group clost
sent Kushner 12 recommendations that
Kushner evidently passed on to the rest
of the White House and while these
suggestions may in fact be legitimate
the questionable method of obtaining
this information to deal with a
worldwide pandemic shows a lack of
preparation to put it mildly which takes
us to part three of this story the
opposite of domestic tranquility
mistakes here are not limited to the
executive branch the Senate has taken
multiple breaks during this crisis
senators have been concerned that if
they leave DC they might not be able to
fly back and yet many senators have
taken these breaks as an opportunity to
go back to their constituents if they
are concerned about not being able to
come back they should probably stay in
DC where they can you know make actual
policy another political own-goal is
that this administration has been
unnecessarily obsessed with being
secretive and classifying coronavirus
information instead of sharing it with
people who could help their reports that
in
pandemic discussions are classified
which of course limits their
accessibility and their reach the head
of the CDC testifying that public health
officials discussed coronavirus
information and classified rooms on
occasions quote too numerous to count
additional reports indicated the
Department of Health and Human Services
treated top-level coronavirus meetings
as classified and that those without
security clearances were excluded from
those discussions it appears that at
least by mid-march the president started
taking things more seriously and on
Wednesday March 11th President Trump
gave his first nationally televised
speech on the subject my fellow
Americans tonight I want to speak with
you about our nation's unprecedented
response to the corona virus outbreak
the most memorable part of the speech
was the European travel ban
unfortunately large portions of this
speech turned out to be incorrect or
fabrications first President Trump said
that all travel to and from Europe was
being banned when he was really
exempting Ireland in the UK and American
citizens could return home he also said
that cargo to and from overseas
locations was being banned that turned
out to be not the case
and third he claimed to have worked out
a deal with insurance companies to cover
the cost of coronavirus testing which
turned out to not be the case
insurance companies agreed to waive
co-pays but not the actual fees for the
tests themselves the travel ban itself
and the lack of clarity surrounding the
particular travel ban had some
unintended consequences as well by now
you've probably seen the video and
photos of people landing in the US and
waiting in long lines the airports which
are under federal jurisdiction can't
handle the influx of international
travelers who were now required to
receive the enhanced coronavirus
screenings which of course has caused
thousands of people to be confined in
very small spaces two days later on
Friday Friday the 13th President Trump
made his second address this time he
announced that he was signing an
emergency declaration due to the corona
virus pandemic to unleash the full power
of the federal government that this
effort today I am officially declaring a
national emergency the national
emergency declaration now allows the
president to do a couple of important
things that many including many in the
medical industry were begging for for a
long time under the Stafford Act the
president can now tap into those FEMA
accounts the money can now be used for a
variety of essential items such as
needed medical supplies testing kits and
equipment for hospitals the emergency
declaration also allows the president to
waive Medicare and Medicaid requirements
including payment limitations for
out-of-network providers in certain
certifications and while the substance
of the speech was well received causing
stock market prices to increase
dramatically the actual speech itself
was notable for the fact that in a
speech about a pandemic Trump was seen
shaking hands with members of the
administration various CEOs touching
their faces touching the microphone and
not setting a great example which is
ironic because this is exactly the same
place where Trump literally looked at
the Sun during an eclipse unfortunately
the speech also had some inaccuracies
and caused additional uncertainty for
instance president Trump vald that
Americans would soon be able to go to
testing sites in places like their local
Walmart parking lots so we've been asked
to make portions of our parking lot
available in select locations in the
beginning and scaling overtime as supply
increases so that people can experience
the drive-through experience that the
president described this was
unfortunately premature as
representatives of Walmart and other
major companies said they had no idea
how the test would be conducted let
alone when it would happen and other
pertinent details president Trump also
announced that Google was developing a
website where Americans could input
their symptoms and find out if a test
was necessary and then be directed to a
testing site near their homes Google is
helping to develop a website to
determine whether a test is warranted
and to facilitate testing at a nearby
convenient location unfortunately that
was news to Google which said that
Google didn't have any of those plans
that its sister site verily was in the
early stages of development of a website
that would be specific for the San
Francisco Bay Area and that that wasn't
even close to being finished
of course other measures are being taken
as well the Fed is attempting
quantitative easing by trying to reduce
interest rates to zero but it's not
clear that this is going to have any
effect on the economy or individuals
because this is both a supply side and
the demand side shock and at the time of
this video there are currently active
negotiations over a bipartisan bill to
provide relief and fight the pandemic
and I think everyone is optimistic that
that's going to be passed sometime very
soon whether it's effective or not will
be a totally separate question so listen
I think we're all on the same page with
hoping that this disease get
eradicated and preventing the loss of
additional lives but there's a
difference between handling something
effectively and trying to control the
narrative to make it look like something
as being handled effectively the
president stated at a fundraiser not too
long ago that they're trying to scare
everyone from meetings canceled the
meetings close the schools you know
destroy the country and that's okay as
long as we can win the election but I
really believe that if they see the
Trump administration is handling this
virus in a professional confident way I
don't believe it's going to hurt us mine
site is of course 2020 but we saw this
unfolding in other countries first we're
not the first country to be hit with
could the corona virus and we should
have been better prepared it looks like
the government is finally starting to
take this seriously but to date no one
would claim that the government's
response has been perfect but just
because the US government doesn't seem
to know what it's doing doesn't mean
that we can't get through this together
we will if we all stick together and the
best thing that you can do right now is
call your parents your friends and
encourage them to stay home for the next
month or so it's more important than
ever to check with the people that you
care about to see if they need help and
one of the best ways to do that is with
ting mobile and as a bonus if you want
to call your parents and tell them to
stop shopping at Costco because they
already have enough supplies to last for
months the call will be super clear ting
Mobile is a different kind of mobile
provider with ting you only pay for the
actual data and services that you use at
the end of the month and because you're
only paying for what you actually use
ting customers pay on average just
twenty three dollars per month from one
of their devices and ting provides great
LTE coverage because it uses the
t-mobile Sprint and now the Verizon
network so you get the benefit of three
massive networks wherever you go with
ting you can use almost any cell phone
including the newest iPhones and pixel
phones and you can use the same phone
number you're using right now there's no
contract no overage fees or any other
carrier tricks you just pay a fair price
for the talk text and data that you use
every month and ting has award-winning
customer service because they don't have
any brick-and-mortar stores they pour
their resources into phone support which
is going to be particularly useful in
this day and age when you're probably
not going to be going to any
brick-and-mortar stores so you can use
their chat email or social media disk
or the old-fashioned telephone to call
ting and switch today and with ting
you'll probably end up saving a ton of
money especially if you're around Wi-Fi
all day which I don't know about you but
I am around Wi-Fi all day whether I want
to be around Wi-Fi or not I'm around
Wi-Fi all day so you'll end up paying
way way less because you'll be using
Wi-Fi instead of your cell phone
coverage sure some people should
probably pay $200 a month for unlimited
data but if you're around Wi-Fi all the
time you might be paying hundreds of
dollars more than you have to
ting gives you the option to pay for
only what you use so if you go to legal
eagle ting comm you can use your last
bill to compare just how much you would
save and legal eagles will get a twenty
five dollar credit by going to legal
eagle tank comm and that could cover the
entire first month of service and since
there are no contracts you can try it
for a month with no strings attached
again all you have to do is go to the
link in the description down there or go
to legal eagle ENCOM and get a twenty
five dollar credit for whatever service
you want plus clicking on the link in
the description really helps out this
channel so do you agree with my analysis
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews
where I tackle the legal news of the day
including whether the government can
quarantine people as it seems that it's
trying to do so click on this playlist
and I will see you in court